WELL [inaudible]
TORONTO [inaudible]
RICARDO.
JONES AND LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
RALPH [inaudible]
THERE [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER YEAH I COUNTY.
HE BROTHER HERE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE INTERN FOR
HELPING US ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
TO A GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME TO
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
HEARING TODAY WE'RE HEARING
EIGHT BILLS ARE PART OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET PACKAGE
SEVEN TRAILER BILLS AND ONE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR.
AS OF TODAY COLLEAGUES WE
ANTICIPATE ONE MORE HEARING.
THIS COMING MONDAY AT TWELVE
NOON ALL OF YOUR OFFICES HAVE
ALREADY BEEN NOTIFIED. TO HEAR
BILLS THAT DID NOT MEET THE
SEVENTY TWO HOUR PRINT RULE AND
THEREFORE COULD NOT BE HEARD
TODAY.
MONDAY AT TWELVE NOON AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THIS WILL BE.
OUR FINAL BUDGET HEARING FOR THE
TWENTY NINETEEN SESSION CAN.
WE'VE ACKNOWLEDGED A QUORUM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR.
THIS ONE OFTEN.
I KNOW YOU ALL ARE IMPRESSIVELY
THANK YOU SENATOR ROBB THANK YOU.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
ON AB SEVENTY FIVE EDUCATION
FINANCE.
THANK NINE ADAM CHAIR YES SIR
HIS FIRST TWO BILLS -- THE
EDUCATION FINANCE AS WELL AS THE
HEALTH ARE PRETTY BIG ON THE BUS
BILLS SO I'LL BRIEFLY DESCRIBE
SOME OF THE ITEMS PLEASED AND
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS ON ANY
ELEMENT OF IT.
SO WITHIN AB SEVENTY FIVE EIGHT
EDUCATION FINANCE TRAILER BILL
THEIR NUMBER OF ITEMS -- RECEIVE
YOUR CONSIDERATION THE FIRST IS
ON FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN -- THE
TRAILER BILL INCLUDES THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS -- FOR
THE EXPANSION OF FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
FACILITIES AND CONVERTING FROM --
PARTE TO FULL DAY FACILITIES A
SECOND ITEM THAT THAT THIS BILL
IS AROUND STATE PRESCHOOL
ELIGIBILITY -- WITH THE PRIORITY
FOR PARENTS WERE WORKING FOR WHO
WERE IN SCHOOL AS WELL AS AFTER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH CONFERENCE.
IF AN AREA HAS 80% OR MORE
STUDENTS WITH FREE OR REDUCED
PRICE MEALS ENABLING ANYONE IN
THAT AREA TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
SLOTS IF THEY'RE NOT OTHERWISE
ALREADY FILLED.
THIRD ELEMENT OF THIS BILL IS
THE CREATION OF THE MASTER PLAN
FOR EARLY LEARNING AND CARE AS
WELL AS FUNDING.
THIS BILL ALSO INCLUDES AN EARLY
CHILDHOOD POLICY COUNCIL IN THIS
BUILD ON THE WORK OF THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION WHICH RECENTLY
RELEASED ITS RECOMMENDATIONS ON
EARLY CHILDHOOD POLICY.
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES FUNDING
FOR THE EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT AS WELL AS
THE EARLY MORNING AND CARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANT --
FOR THE FIRST DOES IT INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER TH NEXT FIVE YEARS
THAT'S A MIX OF STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDS -- AND FOR THE
SECOND INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS AND THAT
COMES FROM STATE MONEY.
THIS BILL ALSO INCLUDES --
SIGNIFICANT -- FUNDING AND
CHANGES -- WITH REGARDS TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION -- IT WILL
BRING ELEAZAR THE STATEWIDE BASE
RATE AND ALSO INCLUDE A SPECIAL
AT THE EDUCATION EARLY
INTERVENTION PRESCHOOL GRANT
PROGRAM THESE ARE FOR THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS WITH AN
INDIVIDUALIZED.
EDUCATION PLAN -- AND THESE THIS
FUNDING IS PREDICATED ALSO ON
THE ON GOING NEED FOR REFORM
THAT MANY OF YOU HAVE SPOKEN
ABOUT SO WE WILL BE TAKING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS VERY SERIOUSLY AS
WE HEAD INTO THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET CYCLE.
A COUPLE FINAL ITEM SAID THERE'S
A NUMBER OF PROVISIONS IN HERE
ON K. TWELVE SEVERAL HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND SETTLE
PAYMENTS THAT'S MONEY OWED FOR
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FOR
PRIOR YEARS.
THERE'S OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
TEACHER GRANTS AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
THERE IS MONEY FOR CLASSIFIED --
SUMMER EMPLOYEE -- CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES TO TAKE SUMMER CLASSES --
THERE'S MONEY FOR A TEN MILLION-DOLLAR LONGITUDINAL DATA STUDY
WHICH IS A BIG PRIORITY OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND I KNOW MANY
OF YOU HAVE.
ENGAGED IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THAT AS WELL THERE SEVEN AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS FOR
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE THERE'S
ALSO -- RE BENCHING OF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE SERVICES FOR PRESCHOOL --
NON LA PROVIDERS THOSE ARE BEING
PULLED OUT OF THE GUARANTEE --
FOR GENERAL FUND ON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT THEREFORE CREATING
MORE ROOM WITHIN THE GUARANTEE
FOR OTHER PROGRAMS -- THE FINAL
THREE ITEMS ALL MENTION OUR SON
A CHARTER SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES -- BACK FILL FOR
WILDFIRES SO OVER THE LAST YEAR
MAKING SURE THAT -- DISTRICTS
ARE MADE HOLE FOR THE MONEY THEY
LOST WHEN PROPERTY TAXES GO DOWN
AND FINALLY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
FOR SPECIAL OLYMPICS FOR BOTH
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SO HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS ON
THOSE OR ANY OTHER ITEMS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTIONS MEMBERS [inaudible]
THIRTY NIELSEN.
THE SAID THE CHARTER SCHOOL
PROVISIONS LIKE [inaudible]
CORRECTLY.
IT'S KIND OF LEVERAGE.
ON CHARTER SCHOOLS.
WHY DO WE HAVE?
TO DEAL WITH CHARTER SCHOOLS.
IN THIS BUDGET [inaudible]
SPIRIT PUNITIVE [inaudible]
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
IN A CHARTER SCHOOL IN THE AREA
THAT BURNED.
UNDER PROVISION HERE WE NOT BE
ABLE TO EVEN OPEN.
WHY ARE WE DEALING WITH CHARTER
SCHOOLS?
TELL MAKE TWO BRIEF COMMENTS AND
THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE JESSICA I THINK THE
FIRST IS SOME OF THE PROVISIONS
IN THIS BILL.
DEAL SPECIFICALLY WITH THE LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS AND
SO THOSE WE FEEL TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL FACT IN TERMS
OF WOW THOSE PLANS WORK HOW THEY
ARE IMPLEMENTED SO WE DO THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT TO DEAL WITH
THAT AS PART OF THAT PROCESS.
THE SECOND REASON AND I KNOW
THIS IS COME UP FOR A LOT OF
DISCUSSION BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
CONVERSATION AROUND THE IMPACT
BETWEEN CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS AND WHEN
STUDENTS ARE ENROLLING IN ONE
VERSUS THE OTHER.
EACH SCHOOL AND EACH SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS TO DEAL WITH THE
FISCAL IMPACTS OF THAT SO WE
THINK THAT.
ANY CHANGES THAT MAKES SENSE
THAT AFFECTS THOSE PREVENT THOSE
FISCAL THAT HAD AFFECTS THAT
FISCAL SITUATION IN THE DISTRICT
IS WORTHY OF CONSIDERATION IN
THIS BILL AND JESSICA MAY WILL.
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SCHOOL HOMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE ONLY THING THAT
WOULD ADD -- IS THATSPECIFICALLY TO YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT THE DISASTER RELATED
FUNDING FOR THE BUDGET DOES
PROVIDE FUNDING TO BACK FILL
LOSS -- AND I'LL SEE IF I
FUNDING AND OTHER TYPES OF
FUNDING STATE FUNDING FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS THE REQUIREMENT
IS THAT THEY MAINTAIN AT LEAST
50%.
OF THEIR AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE SO THAT THEY DON'T
DROP SO LOW THAT YOU KNOW
THEY'RE NOT SUSTAINABLE OVER THE
LONG TERM.
SO THAT IS THE PROVISION THAT WE
HAVE IN THERE ON THE CHARTER
SCHOOL PIECE TO ENSURE THAT --
THIS SCHOOLS THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING MAINTAINED FUNDING FOR
ACTUALLY VIABLE AND CONTINUE ON
TO FUTURE YEARS.
THE CHARTER SCHOOL IN.
IN PARADISE BECAUSE OF THE
DISTINCTIVE STATION.
GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE EVEN
THE LOWER GOAL SO I UNDERSTAND
YOUR OVERALL POSITION THERE BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO HELP
THAT ONE PART CHARTER SCHOOL AND
YOU CANNOT CONVINCE ME THAT THIS
OVERALL PLAN IS NOT.
THE END OF THE DAY.
KIND OF A COVERT WAY OF
ATTACKING.
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
IF WE CAN DO SOME ACCOUNTABILITY
HOW ABOUT FOR K..
TWELVE EDUCATION.
WE CAN'T WE DO SOME MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEM IN THIS
BUDGET ISN'T THAT A PART OF THE
DEAL.
MAYBE YOUR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION WE WILL CONSIDER THAT
AND I COULD ACCEPT THAT.
BUT YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A NARROW FOCUS.
THEN I WANT TO THANK YOU TOO FOR
THE FOR THE GOVERNOR FOR THE AND
THE LEGISLATURE'S FOR THE
SUPPORT FOR THE BOOK A CRITIC
BOOKCASE VOCATIONAL AGRICULTURAL
EDUCATION.
BUT THOSE PROVISIONS INITIAL
[inaudible]
POSITIVE.
IT MAKES IT PRETTY TOUGH FOR ME
TO VOTE. FOR THIS BILL.
BECAUSE OF THE OTHER.
ASIANS THAT ARE OF CONCERN TO ME.
ARE WE REALLY BUILDING EDUCATION.
I KNOW THIS IS A GREAT BOLD MOVE
TO THE FUTURE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BEHIND IT.
THERE'S MERIT TO IT.
BUT SOME OF THE FRANKLY IS A
LITTLE HARD TO TAKE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU AND PRESIDENTE.
MANAGER -- ELABORATE ON THE
SPECIAL TREATMENT FOR LA COUNTY
SCHOOLS YOU KNOW THE I GUESS WE
HAVE A A RATIO OF IT MINISTRY
YEARS TO TEACHERS THAT EXISTS
AND AND THE STATE THEM.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR AN EXEMPTION
AND US IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
PROBABLY THE NATION'S LARGEST OF
THE SECOND NATION'S LARGEST THAT --
JUST HAD A BALLOT MEASURE TO TRY --
TO ENHANCE THEIR THEIR FINANCES
AND HOPEFULLY GET MORE MORE
STUDENTS INTO THE CLASSROOMS --
IF THEY'RE NOT MEETING -- THIS
EXPECTATION ANOTHER WORD
SURFACING TO BE ABLE TO TOP
HEAVY WHY WOULD WE WANT THEM.
TO SEND OUT A LITTLE BIT -- TOO
EASE THEIR ECONOMICS AND
HOPEFULLY GET MORE TEACHERS INTO
THE CLASSROOM TO WHY WE MAKING
EXCEPTIONS WHEN THERE MIGHT BE
OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE.
HAVING THE SAME ISSUES THAT ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO ADJUST.
SO THIS IS AN EXEMPTION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE PROVIDED
TALLY UST IN LAST I THINK THREE
EACH OF THE LAST THREE YEARS.
WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL IS -- IN THOSE YEARS
THEY WERE SINGLE YOU'RE
EXEMPTIONS WITH NO OTHER
REQUIREMENTS WE JUST WAVES THE
THE RATIO REQUIREMENT FOR THE
MEN AND WOMEN INTO THE PENALTY --
BUT THIS YEAR'S -- WAIVER
REQUIRES THAT -- LA REPORT OUT
SPECIFIC DATA THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS
PUT TOGETHER REPORT THAT SHOWS
HOW THEY ARE GOING TO MEET.
ON THE ADMINISTRATOR TEACHER
RATIO IN THE FUTURE SO WHAT IS
THEIR PLAN FOR REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF ADMINISTRATORS SO THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY MEET THAT IN
THE FUTURE.
AND NOT HAVE TO COME TO
LEGISLATURE THE MINISTRATION FOR
WAIVERS ON EACH YEAR OKAY BUT
WHY NOT WHY NOT -- AND THAT
PROVISION TO ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND MAYBE SMALLER BUT
HAVING THE SAME ISSUES AND
GIVING THEM THE SAME OPPORTUNITY
TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE REGULATIONS.
YES I THINK -- IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF -- YOU KNOW
THIS WAS SORT OF THE THE ONE
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT WE HAD
DISCUSSED -- THAT HAD KIND OF
COME IN AND ASKED FOR THIS AND
AND WE HAD DECIDED THAT WE WOULD
GO AHEAD AND DO THAT BUT THAT WE
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THEM -- TO
COME TO US WITH WITH MORE OF A
IT HAS.
IDEA OF HOW THEY WERE GOING TO
TO COME TO COMPLAINTS IN THE
FUTURE.
YOU KNOW I I USE THE JUST -- HOW
MY OWN TIME AND IT'S?
IT WE NEED TO SEE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AT DID DO THEIR BEST
TO TRY TO BRING.
THEIR THEIR ECONOMICS -- INTO --
INTO THE REALM OF OF
CONTEMPORARY SOCIETY AND AND I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY.
HE SAW A BALLOT MEASURE IN LA
FAIL IS BECAUSE THEY FELT THEY
WEREN'T DOING ENOUGH TO KEEP
THEIR THE FINANCES UNDER CONTROL
AND MY FEELING IS IF.
WE ARE GOING TO BE OFFERING
THESE TYPES OF EXEMPTIONS THAT
WE SHOULD BE FAIR AND WE SHOULD
BE UNIVERSALLY ALLOWING THEM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT MAYBE SOME TRENDS
TRANSITION TIME AS WELL -- BUT
THANK YOU FOR ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
SINGING NOT.
SEEN ON ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
TOWARDS THE STRATEGIES THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF CO DOT ORG WE
JUST WANTED TO SPECIFICALLY
APPLIED THE INCLUSION OF THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE COORDINATOR IN
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CAN TO MATURE WITH TECH THAT
WE'VE SPECIFICALLY ALSO ONE ECHO
THE SENTIMENTS OF THE SPEAKER
BEFORE ME AS WELL AS THEIR
INCREASED.
INVESTMENT INTO COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION WRIT LARGE IN THE STAY
IN THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER
PROGRAM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE OF
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
SOLICITATION JUST TO FOLLOW UP
ON MISTER NIELSEN'S COMMENTS
THERE IS.
ONE SCHOOL THAT WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT WON'T MEET THE 50%
THRESHOLD IS TRYING.
TO MOVE BACK TO PARADISE AND IS
UNABLE TO RIGHT NOW AND DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO GET
ANY FUNDING -- BASED ON THE
LANGUAGE AND SO WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE DEPARTMENT
ON THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU IN
AND FINANCE ARE YOU OPEN TO THE
CONVERSATIONS OF THE ONE UNIX IN
THIS SITUATION WITH THE SCHOOL
IN PARADISE.
I'M YES WE ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
SPEAKING WITH FOLKS WITH THEM
AND HAPPY TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS I APPRECIATE THAT
I DO JUNE WILL BE PART OF IT
THANK YOU.
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
[inaudible]
AS SOMEONE.
AND I THANK YOU FOR THAT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB SEVENTY FIVE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS MITCHELL
AYE MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN.
WELL.
BILL I'D ARE ALSO -- ALSO ALL
RIGHT OR TITLE.
JONES.
JONES NO LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MORNING MONEY NINE MORE LOVE.
MORE LOOK NO MORALE.
MORRELL NO PAN.
ROTH ROTH AYE SKINNER
[inaudible]
STERN STONE STONE NO.
NUMBER I'M BURKE I'D BUY KASKI
BECAUSE THE HI [inaudible]
HI.
HER TOTAL LIE.
REMINDS CAM LAST.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS NINE FOUR
WILL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN. FOR I
KNOW COLLEAGUES IN OTHER
COMMITTEES -- WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN ON WE WILL CHECK IN
THE SEA WHERE PEOPLE ARE
COMMITTEES -- SHORTLY UPON
ADJOURNMENT -- NO GUARANTEE THAT
WILL HOLD IT OPEN INDEFINITELY
BUT WE'LL DO THE BEST WE CAN
THANK YOU.
MOVING ON TO AB SEVENTY EIGHT
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH -- A NOTHER
OMNIBUS TRAILER [inaudible]
FINANCE.
A FEW KEY ITEMS OF NOTE IN THIS
OMNIBUS HEALTH BILL -- THE FIRST
IS THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL IN
STATUTE AND THAT WE KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CAME UP DURING
THE PRIOR HEARING AS WELL. TO
THE OFFICE WOULD BE ESTABLISHED
THROUGH THE TRAILER BILL AND I
ANY APPOINTEES AFTER JULY FIRST --
TO THE OFFICE OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
SENATE CONFIRMATION.
A SECOND POINT OF NO IN THIS
BILL IS ON COVERED CALIFORNIA
AUTHORIZING THE CREATION OF
SUBSIDIES UP 26100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL AS WELL AS
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE MODELED
ON THE FEDERAL INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE.
THE THIRD ITEM IS A GRANT
PROGRAM FOR STDS AS WELL AS HIV
AND HEPATITIS C..
FOURTH ITEM IS THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE VALUE BASED PAYMENTS
PROGRAM THIS IS FOR CHRONIC
DISEASE MANAGEMENT AND
PREVENTIVE EFFORTS THAT CAN
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR PATIENTS AS
WELL AS SAVE MONEY DOWN THE ROAD.
THE THIRD IS A REQUEST -- FOR
FEDERAL APPROVAL FOR THE
SCREENING BRIEF INTERVENTION AND
REFERRAL TO TREATMENT SERVICES
PROGRAM THIS IS SPECIFICALLY --
FOR ABUSE BEYOND ALCOHOL SO
OPIATES SERVICES AND OTHER
ILLICIT DRUGS -- ENSURING THAT
MORE PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
TREATMENT SERVICES.
NEXT IS THE RESTORATION AGAIN
THIS ALSO CAME UP AND COMMITTEE
HEARINGS OF A NUMBER OF OPTIONAL
MEDI CAL BENEFITS SPECIFICALLY
AUDIOLOGY SPEECH THERAPY
PODIATRY AND INCONTINENCE CREAMS
AND WASHES -- IN NEXT AFTER THAT
IS THE MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATION
TAX THIS BILL CODIFIES THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
SEEK ENACTMENT AND PURSUE
FEDERAL APPROVAL OF SUCH ATTACKS
WORKING IN CONCERT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION.
A AND THEN FINALLY WITH REGARD
TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S INTENT
SAID TRANSITION MOST OF MEDI CAL --
PHARMACY BENEFIT TO A FEE FOR
SERVICE PROGRAMS -- CONVENING AN
ADVISORY GROUP AND CREATING SOME
REPORTING METRICS FOR THAT
EFFORT TO CONTINUE AS WELL AND
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS ON THESE
OR ANY OTHER ITEMS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SENATOR MORLOCK THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR -- JUST A QUICK
QUESTION ON BILL APPOINT THREE
IMPLEMENTS AND INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE PENALTY.
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND FILL THE
PURCHASE MINIMUM ESSENTIAL
COVERAGE DURING A CALENDAR YEAR
SHOULDN'T IT STATE THAT IT'S
MANDATED TAX PENALTY.
SO -- I'LL HAVE MY CALL I CAN
SPEAK IN MORE DETAIL BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW IT IS A PENALTY AND NOT A
TAX.
IT WOULD BE REPORTED ON THE FORM
FIVE FORTY WHEN YOU PREPARE YOUR
INCOME TAX RETURN.
WELL I I'M NOT SURE WILL BY
WHICH FORM OFF HAND BUT I THINK
TO ANSWER YOUR BROADER QUESTION --
PROPOSITION TWENTY SIX AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW -- REQUIRED A TWO
THIRDS VOTE AND AND ANY TAX
INCREASE EVEN IF IT'S FOR A
SINGLE INDIVIDUAL AND SO FORTH
BUT THERE ARE -- I BELIEVE FIVE
EXCEPTIONS TO THE DEFINITION OF
ATTACKS THAT ARE ENUMERATED IN
THE CONSTITUTION ONE OF WHICH IS --
A PENALTY IMPOSED BY THE STATE
FOR A VIOLATION OF LAW AND
THAT'S WHAT WE BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE HERE AND THAT'S WHY WE DO
THINK THAT IT'S MAJORITY VOTE
BILL.
AND SO YOU'RE ALSO PROPOSING
NEMCO.
TAX IS THAT JUST THE DISCUSSION
OR IS OUT OF TO SET UP FOR IN
THE FUTURE.
THE THE BILL IN THESE SIGNALS
THE INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE
THAT THAT WE PURSUE AN MCO TAXES
THE THERE'S NO TAX AUTHORIZED IN
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR YOU'RE
WELCOME ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION
PUBLIC COMMENT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE APPRECIATE
THE RESTORATION OF CRITICAL MEDI
CAL BENEFITS TO LAWS THAT WERE
CUT OVER TEN YEARS AGO DUE TO
THE BUDGET NOT DUE TO ANY POLICY.
REASONS AND SO THIS IS LONG
OVERDUE WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
THE LANGUAGE AROUND -- THE THE
DATA COLLECTION ON WHO PAYS THE
PENALTY AS IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW -- THE THE THE AMOUNT A
NUMBER OF POOR CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE COULD BE CONTRIBUTING TO THE
SUBSIDY FUND THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
FAIR MCDADE TING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ESPECIALLY THE INFECTIOUS
DISEASE FUNDING FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS RONALD COLMAN HERE
WE HAVE OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA WE ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A PROGRAM.
WITHIN COVER CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE SUBSIDIES THE INDIVIDUAL
TO HELP THEM BUY COVERAGE ALSO
SUPPORT THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
WHICH WILL RAISE REVENUE FOR
THAT PROGRAM ADDITIONALLY
SUPPORTS THE STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY GROUP ON PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS ALSO THE CODIFICATION
SEEKING TO PURSUE THE MCO TAX.
ALSO THE RESTORATION OF OPTIONAL
BENEFITS AND WE SUPPORT THE
REVISION OF THE ACTUARIAL VALUES --
FOR HIGH DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH PLANS
AS WELL THE BRONZE LEVEL PLANS
AND DODD THANK THE LEGISLATURE
AND LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND
DEPARTMENT FINANCE FOR THEIR
WORK THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS.
AFTERNOON THAT KELLY MAC MILLAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT
THE PASSAGE OF THE STATE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE COMBINED WITH
ADDITIONAL FOR DOUBLE SUCH
SUBSIDIES WITH REGARD TO THE B.
B. P. PROPOSAL PROPOSAL WE
BELIEVE THAT BY ADDRESSING ONLY
THE MEDICAL MANAGED CARE.
PLANS THIS PROPOSAL IS MISSING
AN OPPORTUNITY IMPROVE ORAL
HEALTH AND OTHER ASPECTS OF
HEALTH ARE TREATED AS CARP OUT
BENEFITS AND MEDI CAL.
IN REGARDS TO THE PRENATAL AND
EARLY CHILDHOOD BOTH A FOCUS OF
THIS PROPOSAL.
THERE'S A STRONG ASSOCIATION
BETWEEN DONALD DISEASE AN
OVERALL HEALTH AND IMPROVEMENTS
OF REFERRAL AND CROSS
COORDINATION BETWEEN MEDICAL AND
DENTAL PROVIDERS SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED IN THE BPP.
SHAPE THAT NEXT WITNESS.
BARBARA GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WHERE IN SUPPORT OF A NUMBER
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE THE PREMIUM ASSISTANCE
AND WE WERE ESPECIALLY PLEASED
TO SEE LANGUAGE REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT. TO ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE PHARMACY
BENEFIT TRANSITION.
FINAL WITNESS RAINY X.
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY RIGHTS AND
WE LIKE NUMBER SEVENTEEN WHAT
RESTORED THE OPTIONAL BENEFITS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN OUR
MEMBERSHIP AN ORGANIZATION WHEN
THEY LOST THE OPTIONAL BENEFITS.
THEY HAD TO STAY HOME.
PROPRIETARY ESPECIALLY IF YOU
WANNA COME TO DEFEAT.
AN FOR DENTAL TOO BECAUSE MORE
PEOPLE WHO DO NOT HAVE DENTAL
SERVICE AND BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE DENTAL SERVICE.
THE ATTRACTED ALL KINDS OF
ISSUES THAT HAPPENED TO THEM ANY
UNIT EXASPERATED THEIR
DISABILITIES.
AND AS FOR ALL THE OTHER
OPTIONAL BENEFITS IT WAS HIGH
TIME THAT THEY ALL CAME BACK
FISHING CONTINENT CREAMS AND
WASHES A THAT'S A BIG THING WITH
DISABILITY PEOPLE FOOD TOO
BECAUSE THEY END UP BEING IN
WHEELCHAIRS.
WHEN YOU'RE IN A WHEELCHAIR IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO YOU GET SORES
AND IN ALL THESE THINGS SO WE'RE
VERY GLAD THAT CAME BACK I AM TO
RANDY SO WE THANK YOU ALL FOR IT
IS OPTIONAL BENEFITS FROM
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY RIGHTS?
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
WE HAVE A WE'VE GOT A MOTION
THANK YOU SIR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB SEVENTY THE MOTION IS THE
PAST MITCHELL.
HI HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NOBEL.
WELL I ENTER ALSO -- ALSO I
WOULD OTHER.
JONES.
JONES NO LABOR LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MY NAME.
MORE LOCK.
MORE LOOK NO MORRELL.
HELLO PAN.
PAN AYE ROTH SKINNER ALL RIGHT
SKINNER ONLINE STERN
[inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER NUMBER I Y. KASKI BECAUSE
THE I WILL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN.
MOVING ON TO THANK YOU MA'AM
[inaudible] FIVE APPARENTLY.
ITEM THREE AB SEVENTY NINE
MENTAL HEALTH URGENCY
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
THIS IS A MUCH SHORTER BILL SIX
TWO MAIN ITEMS HERE FIRST IS
WITH REGARD TO THE EARLY
PSYCHOSIS INTERVENTION PLUS
PROGRAM.
THIS BILL AMENDS CURRENT LAW TO
ALLOW THE USE OF STATE FUNDS
INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUND FOR THE PURPOSE OF
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM.
THE SECOND ITEM IN THIS BILL IS
TO ALIGN AND EXTEND THE DEADLINE
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
INNOVATION FUNDING FOR COUNTIES
RATHER THAN HAVING THEM THE DEER
TO A SET DEADLINE.
WILL BE BASED ON A PROJECT PLAN
APPROVED BY THE COMMISSION
THAT'S A MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION AND IN ADDITION TO
THOSE TWO ITEMS THERE'S ONE
TECHNICAL CHANGE REGARDING
APPOINTEES.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS.
SEE NONE PUBLIC COMMENT.
PROBLEM WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THURMAN DATING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT PRECIADO.
COME ON RANDY AREA NOW.
CRITICS CALIFORNIA'S DISABILITY
RIGHTS AND STRONG SUPPORT ANY
EARLY PREVENTION IS A VERY
IMPORTANT THING TO HAPPEN.
H. YOU BE SURPRISED THAT WE HAVE
A LOT OF CLIENTS AGAIN ON THE
SAME SIDE TODAY WERE THERE IN
SCHOOL AND I NEVER HAD EARLY
PREVENTION THAT LEADS TO BIGGER
LONGER PROBLEM SO ANYTHING THAT
CAN HELP. TO MOVE THAT FORWARD.
AND IF THIS PROGRAM DOES THAT
AND STRETCHING THE SMALLER
COUNTIES WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE
AS MUCH.
OF MENTAL HEALTH CARE UP THERE
IF WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO HELP
THEM WE APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
SIR APPRECIATE THAT IT'S BEEN
MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVENTY NINE MOTION TO PASS
MITCHELL HI IT'S WHY NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NINE BELL.
NIELSEN MAIL BY TERRAZZO.
THE RESERVOIR AYE PATADA.
JONES -- I JONES I'VE
[inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LIKE -- LE GUY MORROW.
MORRELL HI PAN [inaudible]
RALPH SKINNER.
THERE ARE AYE STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
WHAT COUNTY?
ARE CASKEY I THE CURRENT VOTE IS
NINE ZERO WILL HOLD THAT ITEM
OPEN MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR AB AT HUMAN SERVICES.
FINANCE.
THIS IS ANOTHER BIG BILL WITH A
NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT ALL
DESCRIBE RUEFULLY THANK YOU
FIRST WITH REGARD TO CAL WORKS
THIS TRAILER BILL WOULD INCREASE
THE MAXIMUM GRANT TO ABOUT 50%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL FOR
AN ASSISTANCE UNIT OF ONE THIS
FOR KHAN IN THE BUDGET YEAR --
AT A COST OF OVER THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AN ON GOING COST
OF OVER FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS SO IT'S A BIG INVESTMENT
BUT ONE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
OF SHORT A LOT OF LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE BELIEVE IS VERY
WORTHY.
THE UNDER CAL WORKS THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO EXPAND THE HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS ELIGIBILITY.
IN ADDITION THIS BILL FOR THE
EARNED INCOME DISREGARD RAISES
IT TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
50% OF INCOME EFFECTIVE JUNE
FIRST OF NEXT YEAR.
AS YOUR ANALYSIS NOTES THIS
COMES AT A COST OF SIX POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR BECAUSE THIS GOES
INTO EFFECT CLOSE TO THE END OF
THE BUDGET YEAR.
BUT IN THE FOLLOWING YEAR AND
THE COST TO BE OVER SEVENTY NINE
DOLLARS AND GROW TO NEARLY A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
OVER THE FORECAST PERIOD.
IN ADDITION FOR CAL WORKS STAGE
ONE CAL STATE ONE CHILD CARE FOR
CAL WORKS THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
TWELVE MONTHS CONTINUOUS
ELIGIBILITY. FOR THE HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THIS BILL
ELIMINATES THE CONSECUTIVE
REQUIREMENT -- WITH REGARD TO
THE SIXTEEN DAYS OF SERVICES AND
THIS BILL ALSO RESETS THE CAL
WORKS ASSET LIMITS RAISING THEM
TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS AND IF
YOU HAVE A VEHICLE.
THAT VEHICLE CAN BE UP TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN VALUE
WHEN IT COMES TO CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES THIS BILL DOES A NUMBER
OF THINGS IT'S RENDON'S THE
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM.
IT PROVIDES A COLA FOR THE
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY RATES AND
IT PROVIDES EMERGENCY CARE GIVER
FUNDING.
WITH REGARD TO AYE HSS -- THIS
BILL BASED ON A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS AMONG NUMEROUS
STACEY STAKEHOLDERS --
ESTABLISHES -- AYE HSS AMMO WE
OR RESET SAID AND THEN PROVIDES
A 4% INFLATION FACTOR AND THEN
WITH REGARD TO AGING ITEMS IN
THIS BILL TWO ITEMS OF NOTE
FIRST WITH REGARD TO THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN.
THIS BILL FINDS A QUARTER WE
VISITS -- BY THE OMBUDSMAN
OFFICE TO SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND ALSO IMPLEMENTING
THAT NO AND PROVIDING FUNDING
FOR THE NO WRONG DOOR MODEL.
AND FINALLY WITH REGARD TO RAPID
RESPONSE -- SERVICES FOR
IMMIGRANTS WHEN FEDERAL FUNDING
OR A SUPPORT IS OTHERWISE
UNAVAILABLE THIS BILL PROVIDES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. THREE MORE LOCKED.
ON THE MOP WITH THE I. H. S. S. --
AS IT RELATES TO COUNTIES.
WHO ARE WE USING SUCH A STRONG
STICK?
I CAN YOU CLARIFY A STICK WITH
REGARD TO THE COUNTIES AND HE
LIVES IN YOUR COUNTY FOR NOT
COMING TO A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT.
CHECK A POOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO -- THE THE AMOUNT OF
THE WITHHOLDING THAT WOULD OCCUR
IF.
THE CONDITIONS ARE MET -- THAT
ARE LAID OUT IN THE LANGUAGE --
IS EQUAL 21% OF THE COUNTIES --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
M. A WEEK [inaudible]
SO -- YOU KNOW THAT THE THING TO
REMEMBER ABOUT THIS LANGUAGE IS
IT ONLY APPLIES TO THOSE
COUNTIES TO I DO NOT HAVE AN
EXISTING -- CONTRACTOR -- INTO.
A BARGAINING AGREEMENT IN PLACE --
AND THERE'S SEVERAL STEPS THAT
HAVE TO BE GONE THROUGH BEFORE
YOU WOULD GET TO THAT THE POINT
OF A POTENTIAL PENALTY -- ALL
ALSO NOTE THAT THAT THE LANGUAGE
BEFORE YOU OUT REGARDING THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN IT.
AGREED TO BY -- ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED INCLUDING -- EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTATIVES AND THAT --
COUNTIES.
AND MADAM CHAIR WE HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK ELLIE --
QUESTIONS OR IS THAT.
AT THE FUTURE TODAY -- IS LA
PREPARE TO RESPOND.
SURE.
THANK YOU YOU'RE MORE THAN
WELCOME.
GO AHEAD SIR MORE LAW.
THE SAME QUESTION YOUR THOUGHTS
ON ON I DID I I JUST.
I GUESS MAYBE TO PROP IT UP IT
WAS LIKE WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO TO
ENCOURAGE.
CERTAIN BEHAVIOR WITHOUT THE
STICKERS ARE.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THIS POST
ANY FELLOW AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE WE WEREN'T
PRIVY TO A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAVE OCCURRED
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE BETWEEN THE
COUNTIES?
AND ALL THE INTERESTED PARTIES
ON THIS IT IT SEEMS TO US THAT --
A BE A LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT TO
WEIGH IN ON THE STATUS OF THOSE
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS.
THANKS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
CENTER NIELSEN.
LET ME FOLLOW ON THAT POINT.
YOU KNOW THERE'S SO MUCH. TO
ARGUE IT'S POSITIVE IN THIS
BUDGET.
EXCEPT THE FACT THAT IS GOING TO
GREATLY INFLATED EXPENDITURES
INTO THE FUTURE.
AND PROBABLY GET US INTO A HUGE
DEFICIT.
JUST A FEW YEARS OUT.
BUT IT IS A LITTLE DISTURBING AS
HOW MANY [inaudible]
UNION PROVISIONS HAVE CREPT IN
TO THE BUDGET.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO RESPOND TO
THIS I UNDERSTAND WHY THEY'RE
THERE.
THEN I UNDERSTAND WHY THE
COUNTIES MAY HAVE SAID WELL
WHICH OKAY NOW THE BROUGHT THE
PERCENTAGE DOWN 21%.
BUT IT'S STILL A PUNITIVE.
AND SYMBOLICALLY I THINK IT'S
IT'S HARMFUL.
NOW THE COUNTIES NO THAT THE
STATE IS READY TO WAIT IN AND
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING ANYTIME
THAT THERE'S ENOUGH PRESSURE.
AND STACKED THE DECK AGAINST THE
COUNTIES.
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY.
AND PREVIOUS GOVERNOR.
DUMPED.
A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY.
AND EXPENSE ON OUR COUNTIES
[inaudible]
IN REALIGNMENT.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN RECOMPENSED
FOR THOSE COUNTIES.
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA AND PUT HIM
IN REAL TROUBLE.
MAKES MY POINT THAT I'VE ALWAYS
SAID COUNTIES OF THE STEP
CHILDREN.
IN CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT.
AND THEY ALWAYS [inaudible]
GOOD GRIEF.
AND NOT ALWAYS DOES A STATE KEEP
ITS PROMISE.
WITH THE COUNTIES.
JUST THE STATE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY CAROL WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY ARE WE
STAND SUPPORT OF AB AT WERE VERY
PLEASE WITH.
MANY OF THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL BUT NOTABLY THE INCREASING
TOWERS GRANTS WHICH BEGINS THE
PROCESS OF INDIAN DEEP POVERTY
FOR CHILDREN IN PARTICULAR FOR
THE HOUSEHOLDS OF ONE WE
ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISH THAT.
IN THIS BUDGET WE'RE THRILLED BY
THAT WE WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
HIS.
STEPPING IN AND MAKING THIS
HAPPEN IN THIS BUDGET YEAR
THANKS VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS.
JUSTIN GARRETT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A NUMBER OF
PROVISIONS BILL I'M IN
PARTICULARLY WHEN I HIGHLIGHT.
OF THE LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ENACT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
REVISE THE COUNTY ACCESS EMILY
THIS PROVIDE A FISCAL STRUCTURE
FOR COUNTIES TO MANAGE I JUST
COSTS AND TO CONTINUE TO DELIVER
SERVICES ON BEHALF OF THE STATE.
I'M ALSO REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE INVESTMENTS AND CAL WORKS
CHILD WELFARE AND CHILD SUPPORT
PROGRAMS THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS THROUGH THE COUNSEL.
BUILDING.
I DON'T I CRISTINA BUS HAMILTON
REPRESENTING UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS YOU W. ASKS ME -- I JUST
WANT TO COMMENT WE WE'RE VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
AS ONE OF THE PARTIES THAT
PROPOSED V. -- PENALTY THAT DOES
A GOOD SENATORS OF ASKED ABOUT I
DID WANT TO LEASE JUST ADD THE
INFORMATION THAT.
YOU KNOW IT SINCE I'VE BEEN IN
AND SACRAMENTO'S IT IN SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TEN THIS HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE AND YOU KNOW OUT OF TWENTY
ONE COUNTIES REPRESENTED BY U.
D. W. WE ONLY HAVE.
SIX WITH CONTRACTS IN PLACE AND
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THE CHART AND
WE LOOKED AT THE AVERAGE LENGTH
OF EXPLORATION WE'RE TALKING
OVER THE THIRTY SIX THIRTY EIGHT
MONTHS.
BE WITH THESE CONTRACTS HAVE
BEEN ARE OUTSTANDING RIVERSIDE
COUNTY HASN'T HAD A WAGE
INCREASE SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN SO THAT
FORCES US TO COME TO THE STATE
BECAUSE OUR MEMBERS CANNOT GO
OUT ON STRIKE THEY CARE FOR
ELDERLY PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
YOU KNOW WE'VE A PAST WEEK INTO
THIS BODY TWO YEARS AGO AND SB
NINETY REQUESTING INCENTIVES WE
WANTED CARROTS WE'VE TRIED
CARROTS FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND
AND WE'RE NOW AT THE POINT OF OF
NEEDING STICKS AND SO IJUST
WANTED.
TO PROVIDE THAT CONTEXT THAT
THESE ARE WORKERS WHO MAKE
MINIMUM WAGE THEY CARE FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE AND MOST OF THEM
ARE ON PUBLIC ASSISTANCE AND
THAT'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
SO WE NEEDED TO ADDRESS IT IN
AND THIS IS WHAT WE CAME UP WITH
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS.
I LIKE THAT GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MIGHT THE CARRERA
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE GREAT
WORK YOU'VE DONE AND THIS --
TRAILER BILL AND I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE CAL WORKS
EARNED INCOME DISREGARD --
LANGUAGE THAT HAS BEEN PUT IN --
TO HELP WORKING FAMILIES IN THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THE THE THE SUPPORTS
THEY NEED SO THAT THEY CAN DO
YOU KNOW GO TO WORK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
[inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
IT BE EIGHTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS MITCHELL HI I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN KNOWN BELL BUT I'D ARE
ALSO [inaudible]
HER TOTAL [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LABOR.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MONEY [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
LOOK NO MORRELL [inaudible]
PAN[inaudible]
ROTH.
I SKINNER SKINNER ONLINE STERN
STONE.
STONE NO AMBERG BY KASKI BUT
BECAUSE THE I THANK YOU MY
FINGER BROWN.
OF THE THE MEASURE CURRENTLY HAS
SIX THREE WILL HOLD IT OPEN WITH
ON COLLEAGUES TO ITEM.
SIX ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT FINANCE.
THE ONE CLARIFICATION MADAM
CHAIR DID YOU -- I SKIPPED ITEM.
FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY ONE
DEVELOPMENTS SERVICES
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
THIS BILL ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
ONE TAKES A NUMBER OF STEPS WITH
REGARD TO DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
CHIEF AMONG THEM IS PROVIDING
THE LANGUAGE IMPLEMENTING THE
RATE INCREASES THAT WERE
DISCUSSED IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
FOR CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
AT NAY REVISION THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD PROPOSED A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
GROWING TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN BUDGET YOUR PLUS.
ONE UNDER THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED THIS WOULD BE A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GROWN TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN BUDGET
YEARPLUS.
ONE THESE RATE INCREASES WOULD
BE TO A MORE BROAD BASED
APPROACH THEY WILL BE UP TO
EIGHT POINT 2% AND WOULD BE DATE
BASED ON THE RATE STUDY DATA
THAT WAS RELEASED EARLIER THIS
YEAR -- SO THAT'S THE MAIN ITEM
IN THIS BILL IN ADDITION THIS
BILL INCLUDES A NUMBER OF ITEMS
RELATED TO IMPROVEMENTS TO
REGIONAL CENTER OPERATIONS AND
GOVERNANCE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
PROVIDING BETTER REPORTING
INCLUDING REGIONAL CENTERS
PRESENTING DATA ANALLY ON
QUALITY AND OUTCOMES AS WELL AS
PROVIDING PERFORMANCE DASHBOARD
FROM EACH CENTER -- AND THOSE
REGIONAL CENTERS SHOULD ALSO BE
UPDATING THE LEGISLATURE
QUARTERLY -- IN BRIEFINGS ON HOW
THEY ARE DOING AND HOW THEY'RE
PURSUING ACCOUNTABILITY IN OTHER
FORMS.
IN ADDITION THE BILL CALLS ON
THAT STATE GOVERNMENT TO
AUTHORIZE STAKEHOLDER WORKGROUPS
FOR BROADER SYSTEM REFORMS THESE
ARE ONE PART OF WHICH THAT RACE
STUDIES ALSO PART.
OF HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT THE
SYSTEM CAN.
SURVIVE PEOPLE IN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY SYSTEM
MUCH BETTER AND AT LOWER COST SO
THE OVERALL GOAL OF THIS BILL IS
MORE FUNDING BUT ALSO APPEARED
WITH MORE ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
PURSUE THE REFORM IN
ACCOUNTABILITY CONVERSATION.
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS COLLEGE.
THIRTY NIELSEN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS IS CERTAINLY -- BILL WORTHY
OF SUPPORT.
THE DD COMMUNITY I THINK IS --
HAD A LOT OF SETBACKS.
I BECAME VERY SENSITIVE TO THIS
COMMUNITY WHEN I FIRST.
WAS ELECTED YEARS AGO
REPRESENTIN.
SONOMA STATE HOSPITAL THAN
HAVING GREATER UNDERSTANDING.
OF WHAT DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ARE AND THE IMPACTS
ON INDIVIDUALS FAMILY AND
SOCIETY.
TOWARDS THAT END AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE IN THESE WORKING
GROUPS THAT CERTAINLY THE
FAMILIES.
OF DEVELOPMENT DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS.
THE GIVEN A LOT OF IMPORT.
IN THE FUTURE THAT IS -- ONE OF
THE GREAT CHALLENGES FOR PARENTS
OF THE DEVELOPMENT A DISABLED
CHILD.
AS A GROW UP WHAT WILL BE THERE
OR HERE FOR THEM.
THIS IS A POSITIVE STEP WHEN I
COMMEND.
THE GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
FOR MOVING THIS DIRECTION.
REPUBLICANS MAY THAT A VERY HIGH
PRIORITY.
AND WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE SOME
PROGRESS UP FOR THAT I THANK YOU.
SENATE IS DOWN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE THE THE
INCREASES AT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE TODAY BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE A PROGRAM THAT IS OF A
BILLION DOLLARS UPSIDE DOWN AND
IT'S CERTAINLY BEEN FELT -- HIT
THE INLAND REGIONAL CENTER WHERE --
YOU HAVE FORMER CONTRACTORS IT
WILL NO LONGER CONTRACT ANYMORE
WHICH MEANS WE HAVE -- A
DECREASE ACCESS TO SERVICE FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS --
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
CERTAINLY THE INLAND REGIONAL
CENTER TATERS DOUBLE STANDARD IN
ACCOUNTING AND AND BURST I
COUNTY WHICH AS A COLLECTIVE
POPULATION ABOUT FIVE NINE
PEOPLE.
SO.
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS IF NOT
NOW WHEN WE HAVE A TWENTY ONE
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET SURPLUS.
CAN I JUST I JUST CAN'T
COMPREHEND WHY -- I I ASSUME
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS A SOFT
HEART FOR THOSE DEVELOPING
DISABLED.
KIDS AND ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA
BUT ACTIONS SPEAK LOUDER THAN
WORDS WE HAVE A RATE STUDY
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON WE AS A
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE -- THREE
ACTUALLY WITH.
PUSHED A VOTE. TO SHOW A WE
SUPPORTED IN 8% ACROSS THE BOARD
INCREASE.
SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE -- THE RESTORATION OF
SERVICES THAT WERE -- DECIMATED
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
AND NOW I SEE THAT -- WERE KIND
OF CHERRY PICKING THOSE SERVICES
THAT WILL GET SOME INCREASES
SOME TWO TO EIGHT POINT 2% TO
THE NUMBER SERVICES ARE GOING TO
STILL GET [inaudible] ZERO SO.
HOW CAN WE -- ARTICULATED THE
GOVERNOR IS IN THE CORNER.
OF THOSE DEVELOPING DISABLED
KIDS AND ADULTS THAT.
DON'T HAVE THE HIGH PRICE
LOBBYIST COMING HERE IN FIGHTING
FOR THEM THEY DEPEND ON US TO
ENSURE THAT.
THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED
SOMETIMES DEPEND ON TO LIVE FOR
YOU KNOW -- ARE AVAILABLE I HAVE --
A CONSTITUENT PETER THAT I I
LIKE TO GO SEE IN.
DESERT HOT SPRINGS AND THE SO
WONDERFUL YOUNG MAN -- IS A
PARAPLEGIC -- LIVES WITH A
RESPIRATOR PASSED HAVE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR CARE.
COMMUNICATES THROUGH AN OPTICAL
MOUSE.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT HE
CAN GET A GOOD NIGHT'S SLEEP.
KNOWING THAT HE CAN HAVE THAT
TWENTY FOUR HOUR SERVICE BECAUSE
HE CAN'T HE CANCEL COME TO US.
A SIXTY MINUTE DELAY IT WITH
ELECTRICITY GOING OFF AND HIS
RESPIRATOR.
NOT FUNCTIONING APPROPRIATELY --
WILL BE HAVE SUCH BUDGET
SURPLUSES WHY ARE WE PUTTING A
BIGGER DOWN PAYMENT ON A
RESTORATION THOSE RATES. TO
ENSURE THAT.
THE NEEDIEST OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
ARE ARE GETTING SERVICES AT A
TIME WHEN WE ARE SPENDING MONEY --
IN OTHER AREAS THAT DON'T HAVE
THE THE MEDICAL SIGNIFICANCE THE
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY THAT.
THESE KIDS AND ADULTS NEED.
I'LL MAKE A COUPLE OF BRIEF
COMMENTS AND MY COLLEAGUE TO
RESELL WILL SPEAK TO IT AS WELL
I THINK THE FIRST IS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE GOVERNOR
YOU ARE RIGHT THIS IS A SHARED
PRIORITY AND IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. TO EVERYONE -- WITH
REGARD TO THAT FINDING -- YOU'RE
ALSO CORRECT THAT A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET -- PLUS --
ONE THAT'S NOT BY ITSELF GOING
TO SOLVE EVERY PROBLEM BUT WE DO
BELIEVE IT IS A MEANINGFUL
COMMITMENT AND DEPENDING ON THE
FISCAL SITUATION YOU KNOW WE
HOPE IT'S THE FIRST STEP OF A
BROADER COMMITMENTS -- BUT
BECAUSE THIS IS AN ONGOING
PROGRAM INTO YOUR POINT IN THE
STORY THAT YOU TOLD THESE ARE
ISSUES THAT DON'T GO AWAY AFTER
A YEAR WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR BROADER BUDGET CAN
SUPPORT THAT.
WITH REGARD TO THE RATE
INCREASES SPECIFICALLY -- SINCE
OUR NAY REVISION NOW WE DID HEAR
THE FEEDBACK FROM THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THOSE RATE
INCREASES DO NEED TO BE MORE
BROAD BASED AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THAT IS REFLECTED IN THIS
PROPOSAL BUT TERESA MY COLLEAGUE
CAN SPEAK TO THAT IS THANK YOU.
THE COLOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS CRACKED THE MAYOR VERSION
WHICH WAS A MUCH MORE TARGETED
APPROACH WITH HIGHER PERCENT FOR
FEWER CATEGORIES ARE IS ABOUT
FIVE SERVICE CATEGORY SAID IT
LOOKED AT UNDER THIS BROAD BASED --
APPROACH YOU'RE RIGHT THERE ARE
SOME THAT IN INDICATED IF
THEY'RE INDICATING THE RATE
STUDY WOULD HAVE A ZERO OR
NEGATIVE PERCENTAGE ADJUSTMENT
FOR THE RATE STUDY -- FINDINGS
THAT THOSE WOULD NOT RECEIVE AN
INCREASE UNDER THIS SO THAT IS
CORRECT.
OKAY THANKS EXPLANATION NAIVE --
I APPRECIATE THE THE INCREASES
THAT ARE BEING GIVEN THAT WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO TO GIVE --
THE KIND OF SERVICES THAT I
THINK THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WANTS TO BE KNOWN FOR FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITIES AND FUTURE ANSWERS
[inaudible]
FOLLOWED BY.
YES I'M VERY PLEASED TO SEE THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS.
OF ALLOCATED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
BUT THE WAY KIND OF I LOOK AT
THESE ARE.
FUNDS THAT ARE GOING TO
INDIVIDUALS.
PEOPLE I SEE EVERY WEEK.
THAT HAVE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
AND WHAT I SEE WHEN I SEE THESE
PEOPLE AS I SEE.
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WORKING IN
THERE.
OF SUPPORT SERVICES LEAVING
BECAUSE THEIR WAGES ARE SO LOW.
I SEE -- OF THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
THE RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITIES CLOSE I'D LIKE YOU TO
SIT DOWN FOR MEDICAL USE THAT
SOME THE KIND OF BOTHERED ME A
LITTLE BIT OKAY.
THE RESIDENTIAL THE RESIDENTIAL --
IT MEANT FACILITIES ARE CLOSING
THERE'S HUNDREDS OF RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES ARE CLOSING
ESPECIALLY IN HIGH COST HOUSING
AREAS LIKE MINE.
SO WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS THE
THEIR CLOSING AND THE THE THE
FACILITIES ARE CLOSING.
AND ARE NOT BEING REPLACED BY
OTHER HOUSING SO.
THERE'S NO PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO
LIVE.
ARE WE IN FACT HAVE HOMELESS
DEVELOP ME DISABLED PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE ALL SAID AGAIN WE HAVE
HOMELESS DEVELOPMENT DISABLED.
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO.
WHEN WE SAY WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT
CUTTING THE COST OR THINGS LIKE
THAT I THINK THAT'S A MISNOMER I
DON'T I DON'T BUY THAT?
I SAY THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED.
AND I SAY THANK GOODNESS FOR
GOVERNORS AND PUT IN SOME MORE
MONEY INTO IT.
THANK GOODNESS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
OF FUNDING THE HEALTH CARE.
THAT THERE NEEDED AND THAT WAS
DONE BECAUSE WE STARK.
IT IT TO OURSELVES TO PAY FOR IT
BY RAISING TAXES AND PAYING
CLOSE EFFORT EXTRA.
MCO TAXES AND OTHER OTHER TAXES
TO PAY.
FOR AND I THINK THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA WILLING TO SUPPORT
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES.
JUST TAKE A POLL.
IT'S VERY CLEAR.
SO I I WOULD LIKE TO APPLAUD
EVERYBODY THAT WORKED ON THIS.
I THINK THIS IS VERY GOOD WE DID
A VERY GOOD JOB IS NOT THE END
GOT A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
BUT IT WAS A BREAK A BREATH OF
FRESH AIR THIS YEAR COMPARED TO
THE PAST.
AND I APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY SO WHEN WE GET TO
STAKEHOLDER GROUP TOGETHER.
LET'S THINK ABOUT [inaudible]
THE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE BEING SERVED.
THE FAMILIES THE PEOPLE AND AND
THE WORKERS THAT ARE THERE IN
THE SYSTEM LET'S FIND OUT WHAT
THEY THINK.
THIS TO A SURVEY OF THEIR THEIR
NEEDS.
AND THEN ALSO I SAY THIS THERE'S
A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE.
THAT ARE DEVELOPING DISABLED
CALIFORNIA.
THEY DON'T GET ANY SERVICE.
SO OUR JOB IS TO FIND THEM.
AND TO SERVE THEM.
THAT'S WHAT THE LETTERMAN ACCESS
FIND THEM ANSWERED WE GOTTA FIND
OUT WHO THEY ARE THEY ARE
GETTING THE SERVICES.
AND AND THOSE SOME OF MICHAEL'S
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR BAIL
AND AND PLEASE UNDERSTAND IT WAS
NO DISRESPECT INTENDED --
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE IS
COME OVER AND THEY'RE KNOCKING
ON OUR DOOR BECAUSE THEY ARE
WAITING FOR FINANCE TO GO
PRESENT ON A CRITICAL TRAILER
BILL -- AND SO THAT'S WHY MISTER
THIS ONE OFTEN WAS ABOUT TO
LEAVE WE APPRECIATE THAT I'VE
SEEN THEM COME IN THE DOOR TWICE
TRYING TO GET YOU SO PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
WE APPRECIATE YOU TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOUR YOUR OFFICE AT ANY
TIME AFTER THE HEARING.
THANK YOU FOR THAT -- SENATOR
STERN.
BIOLOGIST I'LL JUST ADD ON IS
MISTER VISWANATHA AND GOES AND
RUNS AROUND THIS BUILDING AND
DOING HIS DUTIFUL WORK AND WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT SIR WE KNOW YOU
GOT A LOT ON YOUR PLATE --
KEEPING THE PROMISE IS WHAT
WE'VE BEEN ENDEAVORING TO DO
THIS YEAR IN THE LEGISLATURE.
I THINK.
WE HAVE ALL THE BONES OF A
PROMISING BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT
ON THIS PORTION OF THE BUDGET.
I KNOW THERE'S SOME
CONSTERNATION AND RIGHTLY SO
THAT.
THE PROMISE IS NOT YET FULLY
FULFILLED.
WHAT CAME OUT OF THE BUDGET
SEVEN I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FROM SANGER STEPPING UP IN
IN HER BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AND
MAKE AN IMPORTANT MOTION IN?
MY COLLEAGUES FROM ALL OF THIS
STATE AND STEPPING UP -- YOU
KNOW WE'VE HAD -- I THINK BY THE
NUMBERS ABOUT FORTY EIGHT
HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS LOSE CARE
IN THE PAST NINE YEARS.
THIRD OF THE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND STAFF THAT WE HAVE IS
LEFT THE PROFESSION DUE TO
SUBSTANDARD WAGES.
YOU KNOW THE THIRD BY THE MOST
RECENT DATA WE'VE SEEN THAT HAVE
TO ACTUALLY WORK A SECOND JOB TO
AVOID FALLING INTO POVERTY SO
WHILE THEY'RE DOING THIS JOB
THAT IS NOT LIKE A NORMAL JOB.
THIS ISN'T YOU KNOW -- FIXING
WIDGETS THIS IS PEOPLE -- SO
WITH HIS.
TRULY HUMAN -- CHALLENGE I THINK
WERE UP FOR IT APPRECIATE THE
PROGRESS WE'RE MAKING.
I REALLY HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL
TRY TO FIND A WAY TO SAY YES AND
HOLD HANDS TOGETHER AND MOVE
THIS FORWARD.
AND NOT DIVIDE OURSELVES OVER
THE PROMISE YET NOT FULLY
FULFILLED -- SO THANK YOU TO
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND FOR ALL
THE LEADERSHIP AROUND THIS DIET
SO WORK ON THIS ISSUE I'M HOPING
WE CAN.
WE CAN JUST JUST SAY YES AND
LET'S PUT THE POLITICS BEHIND US
AND MOVE FORWARD AND HELP THIS
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT FINISHED
SENATOR STERN AND I WILL JUST
SAY FINALLY -- HAVING CHAIRED
BUDGET SUB THREE IN THE SENATE
SUB ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY DURING
THE YEARS WHERE I DON'T HAVE TO
WAIT AND GO HOME AND TALK TO A
CONSTITUENT ALL THE LAB DONE
THAT.
BUT THOSE HEARINGS WHERE --
RECIPIENTS LINED THE HEARING
ROOM IN THE HALL.
AND ASK US THE TOUGH QUESTION IF
YOU ARE CUTTING HOURS TO MY AYE
HSS WHAT HOURS OF THE DAY WOULD
YOU SUGGEST I NOT HAVE CARE --
AND SO MANY OF US LIVE THROUGH
THOSE VERY VERY TOUGH HEARING TO
TOUGH YEARS WORK SERVICES WERE
CUT.
AND SO I AM PROUD TO VOTE ON A
BUDGET BILL IN CHIEF.
AND A TRAILER BILL.
THAT PUTS DOLLARS TOWARD.
THE SERVICE WITH THE BILL.
THANK YOU FOR CUTTING THE OXYGEN
ALWAYS.
RIGHT I WAS READY TO GO THANK
YOU. TO OUR CALVET GOT ME INTO
THEIR PUBLIC COMMENT.
CALIFORNIA'S THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS.
SENATE MITCHELL SENATE ALL.
WE THANK THEE WE THANK THEM
MEMBERS WE THANK THE GOVERNOR.
AND WE THANK EVERYBODY FOR
COMING OUT AND SUPPORTING DDS
DDS IS ALWAYS BEEN CUT AND ONE
OF MY FAVORITE ONE IS REQUIRES A
LIST OF GREED UPON SERVICES
PROVIDED TO CONSUMERS AT THE
CONCLUSION UNDER AYE PP.
AND I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE THEIR I. P. P.'S A
NAY SAY THAT'S A GOOD IDEA BUT
WE CAN'T SERVE YOU.
THIS WOULD IN DOUBT AND WE THANK
YOU FOR THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHELLE RODGERS I AM I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE EARLY
LEARNING INSTITUTE IN CINEMA
COUNTY I AM ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA'S AMBASSADOR TO THE
CDC AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
I APPRECIATE THE EXTRA MONEY
GOING INTO THE BUDGET FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES I AM APPALLED THAT THE
INFANTS AND TODDLERS ARE
COMPLETELY LEFT OUT.
THAT RATE STUDY WHICH IS STILL
IN PROGRESS HAS BEEN SENT BACK
FOR A REVISED AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THE RATE STUDY YOU CAN SEE THAT.
THE INFANTS AND TODDLERS WERE
LEFT TO THE VERY END WHEN WE
TALKED WITH THE CONSULTANTS
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN PART OF THE
INFILL DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATION
WHO IS SITTING ON THAT RATE
COMMITTEE.
THEY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT OUR SYSTEM
IS VERY COMPLICATED THEY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND IT AND THEY DIDN'T
GET VERY MUCH INPUT FOR IT.
THE BASS LINE.
OUR PRODUCTIVITY NUMBER THAT
THEY'RE GIVING US TO USE IS
TWENTY SEVEN POINT FIVE HOURS A
WEEK.
I RUN AND EARLY INTERVENTION
AGENCY WITH HOME VISITTION FOR
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY KIDS.
I CAN TELL YOU IF I COULD GET MY
STAFF TO BILL TWENTY SEVEN HOURS
A WEEK THEY'D BE DOING IT.
I'VE BEEN RUNNING THE EARLY
INTERVENTION THE EARLY LEARNING
INSTITUTE FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
I KNOW THE BUDGET INSIDE AND OUT
FOR EARLY INTERVENTION AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT MY TEACHERS.
MAKE NINETEEN TO TWENTY ONE
DOLLARS AN HOUR AND THEY HAVE
MASTER'S DEGREES SO FOR SOMEONE
TO SELL ME THAT WE ARE OVERPAID.
I'M I DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR NUMBERS WE HAVE
SIX PT'S LEFT IN CINEMA COUNTY
THAT WORK IN EARLY INTERVENTION
WE HAVE.
FOR SPEEDING SPECIALIST.
I SENATOR BILLSAID IT'S OUR JOB
TO FIND FOLKS WITH DISABILITIES
AN EARLY START AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL I A SIT ON A COMMITTEE
THAT SAYS CALIFORNIA IS NOT
FINDING THEIR CHILDREN.
AND NOW I HAVE TO GO BACK AND
TELL THEM NOT ONLY ARE THEY NOT
FINDING THEIR CHILDREN THEY'RE
NOT FUNDING OUR THE SERVICES
WHEN WE DO FIND THEM.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO MY STAFF AND
SAY THE PEOPLE DOWN THE STREET
GET AN 8% INCREASE AND WE GET
ZERO AND WE POSSIBLY GET
NEGATIVE.
SO WE KNOW THE STUDIES GOING TO
BE RE DONE WE KNOW THE STUDY IS
IN PROGRESS AND WILL COME BACK
TO US IN SEPTEMBER WHAT WE'RE
ASKING IS THAT THERE IS SOME.
LEGISLATIVE EITHER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE OR PRESSURE ON DDS THAT
SAYS UNTIL THAT -- BILL COMES
BACK INTO THE RATE STUDY COMES
BACK WE ARE INCLUDED.
I'M OR WE ARE HELD OUT UNTIL IT
COMES BACK WITH THE CORECT
NUMBERS AND THEN WE ARE WILL BE
INCLUDED IN JANUARY.
BUT TO JUST LEAVE US OUT
COMPLETELY FOR GOVERNOR WHO SAYS
THAT EARLY CHILDHOOD AND INFANTS
AND TODDLERS ARE HIS PRIORITY IS
REALLY UNCONSCIONABLE.
SO I APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU CAN BE ABOUT
THE BABIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
CARL LUNDEN HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING THE ALLIANCE
SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES I WANT.
TO START BY THINKING YOURSELF
THINKING THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE PICKLE SAT MICKEY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES. FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO REALLY GO
OVER THIS ISSUE THIS YEAR.
AND MAKE AN EXHAUSTIVE EFFORT AT
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IT.
YEAH AND TO HELP FUND IT I
REALLY WANT TO THANK.
THE LEGISLATURE FOR JUMPING IN
AND HELPING THE GOVERNOR FIND A
COMPROMISE TO THE MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL WE PUT OUT WHICH
ORIGINALLY ONLY FUNDED A FEW
CATEGORIES OF SERVICES.
IN THE SPACE AND INSTEAD NOW
TAKES A MUCH MORE BROAD BASED
APPROACH TO FUNDING -- I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS FOR
SUSPENDING THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE ISSUE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IT.
CLEARLY ELIMINATED BUT A TWO
YEAR SUSPENSION IS VERY HELPFUL.
AND LAST I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING LANGUAGE AT THE WILL
BE OVERSIGHT.
OF THE RATE STUDY AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS AROUND
THE RATE STUDY OPTICALLY WANT TO
THANK.
CENTER STERN FOR HIS ROBUST
LEADERSHIP AND PICKING UP THE
TORCH OF HIS FORMER BOSS CENTER
PAVLEY WHOSE -- APPARENT JUST
LIKE I AM IN THE SYSTEM.
WHEN I THINK CENTER STONE FOR
HIS ADVOCACY CENTER GROVE FOR
HER STALWART ADVOCACY -- CENTER
HER TITLE FOR REALLY JUMPING IN
AND SENATE BUDGET SUB THREE AND
MAKING AN EXTRA EFFORT THERE TO
HELP DIRECT THE SHIP THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
THIS PROPOSAL STILL FALL SHORT
AND WANT TO TELL YOU HOW AND THE
FIRST THING I WOULD SAY IS WERE
WIDELY ACKNOWLEDGING THE NEEDS
OF THE SYSTEM.
BUT WE DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE RATE INCREASES TOLD TILL
JANUARY.
ONE THAT THAT IS TO ME NOTHING
MORE THAN A COST SAVINGS MEASURE
WE'RE TRYING TO SAVE A HALF
YEARS PAYMENTS TO YOU GUYS.
WE THINK THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM
THE RATE STUDY WANT TO BE VERY
CAREFUL AND AND JUST SUGGEST
THAT WE NOT ALL FALL INTO THE
TRAP.
OF ALLOWING PEOPLE TO REFER TO
THE RATE STUDY FOR THE CHANGES
THEY PROPOSE BUT THEN NOT
RECOGNIZING OTHER PIECES OF THE
RATE STUDY AND THUS FAR THE RATE
STUDY THAT'S OUT THERE.
HAS RECEIVED PUBLIC COMMENT WE
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S OUT WITH
THOSE PUBLIC COMMENTS WITH THE
RESPONSE IS GOING TO BE MANY OF
THEM ARE METHODOLOGICAL COMMENTS
FLAWS IN THE RATE STUDY THE ROOM
POINTED OUT.
IN THE WE'VE ASKED TO HAVE
CHANGED AND SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
LIKE THE ONE FROM THE WOMAN YOU
JUST -- FROM A SECOND AGO MAY BE
AT A POINT WHERE WE RECEIVING
NOTHING.
IN THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE THE
RATE STUDY SAYS THE SHOULDN'T
YET PEOPLE ARE POINTING OUT
FLAWS IN THE METHODOLOGY THAT
WAS USED TO ARRIVE AT THAT.
UNTIL THAT SETTLED WE THINK
THAT'S OF WHAT STUDY OR AT LEAST
AN INCOMPLETE STUDY ONE THING WE
RECOMMEND YOU SERIOUSLY CONSIDER
DOING BETWEEN NOW AND THE END OF
SESSION BECAUSE YOU PROBABLY
FUNDING. TO THE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE LEFT OUT IN THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL.
SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS STILL
FACE ALL THE RISING COST OF
LIVING.
THE FACT THAT MINIMUM WAGE IS
GOING TO GO UP BY OVER 80% IN
JANUARY ALL THE OTHER COSTS
ASSOCIATED LABOR -- INSURANCE
TRANSPORTATION ALL THOSE COSTS
ARE STILL GONNA FACES PROGRAMS
THE TODAY OR OPEN THEIR LEGAL
THEY'RE PROVIDING SERVICES THAT
ARE IN SOMEBODY'S IPP SITTING IN
A REGIONAL CENTER FILE SOMEWHERE.
THERE BEEN APPROVED AND YET
THEY'RE RECEIVING NO INCREASE IN
OF THIS PROGRAM WE THINK IT A
LOOK AT THAT IT DOESN'T TAKE A
LOT IT WOULD BE A SKINNY
PROPOSAL. TO GIVE THEM SOME SORT
OF INCREASE TO SHOW GOOD FAITH.
WE ALSO THINK YELL AT VERY
SERIOUSLY AT TO THE POLICIES
THAT ARE LEFT OVER FROM THE
RECESSION ERA.
THERE ARE TWO POLICIES IN PLACE
ONE IT REQUIRES HALF THE BILLING
PROCEDURES ACOSTA LOTTA HAVOC IN
THE SYSTEM.
THAT ISN'T THAT DATES BACK TO
THE RECESSION IN THE STATE WE
ARE NOT IN A RECESSION WHY ARE
WE KEEPING IN A PLACE SECONDLY.
SOCIAL WRECKING CAMP PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN DE FUNDED SINCE THE
RECESSION WE'RE NOT A RECESSION
WHAT I'LL TELL YOU ABOUT THAT.
IS THAT HIS PEOPLE THE HAVE NOTS
WORSE THAN ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE A TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD IS
A KING UP THIS WEEK.
BECAUSE I CAN AFFORD THAT BUT I
HEARD TESTIMONY.
IN THIS SUBCOMMITTEE OF PEOPLE
WHO CANNOT AFFORD THAT AND THAT
IS THE ONLY.
OPPORTUNITY THOSE PEOPLE OUT FOR
SOCIAL INTERACTION.
WE CAN'T HAVE RECESSION ERA CUTS
STAY IN PLACE FOR NO GOOD REASON
OF THEM WE JUST WANT TO CHANGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS. FOR PRESS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SPEECH
LANGUAGE HEARING ASSOCIATION
CASSIA -- I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
SAID BUT I ALSO WANT TO ADD THAT
THIS AT THE RESOURCES THAT WE
PUT INTO THESE EARLY
INTERVENTION.
ZERO TO THREE HAS A SUBSTANTIAL
COST SAVINGS TO THE K. TWELVE
SYSTEM BECAUSE THOSE CHILDREN
WHEN THEY MOVE FORWARD TO GET TO
READ THREE YEARS OLD.
INTO THE K. TOLL SYSTEM WITHOUT
THOSE SERVICES AND I'M TOLD BY A
SO PEAS PT'S -- TEASE OUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT THEY
WILL BE CLOSING I'M IS NOT A
THREAT IS A REALITY THEY WILL BE
CLOSING.
SO THOSE SERVICES WILL NOT BE
ALLOWED OR BE ABLE TO BE
PROVIDED TO OUR CHILDREN.
AND NOT ONLY IN THE IN THIS
ORDER THREE POPULATION BUT ALSO
WHEN THEY MOVE INTO THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM AS WELL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR VERY
JORDAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
I WANT TO ALSO EXPRESS GRATITUDE
TO TO THE DICE ON LOOKING AT
TODAY I LOOK UP THERE AND I SEE
A A DISTINGUISHED DIES THAT.
EVERYONE UP THERE'S EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
IT'S BECAUSE OF THAT SUPPORT
WE'VE GOTTEN BIPARTISAN BOTH
HOUSES AT LEGISLATURE.
THAT WE'VE GOTTEN TO THE POINT
NOW WHERE WE ARE MAKING SOME
PROGRESS ON ON THE CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING OF OUR SYSTEM.
PARTICULAR ONE IS I WANT TO
SIGNAL A SINGLE OUT CENTER STERN
FOR HIS EFFORTS IN LEADING A
PERCENT CAMPAIGN -- ON THE
SENATE SIDE WE DID COME A LONG
WAY THIS YEAR AND I WANT TO KNOW
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION CAME OFF
THEIR MAY REVISED PROPOSAL.
THEY DO.
RECOGNIZE A MORE BROAD BASED
NEED AND WE DO HOPE THAT THIS IS
THE FIRST STEP MY BIG CONCERN OF
COURSE IS WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
DOWN THE ROAD IS THIS TRULY A
FIRST STEP IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF A RATE STUDY THE CALLS.
FOR SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT AND
SYSTEMS REFORMS OR IS THIS JUST
A WAY TO MAKE US GO AWAY FOR A
COUPLE YEARS SO I WANT TO I WANT.
TO ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH US WE ARE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO PUT IN THE
WORK WE KNOW THAT YOU ARE AS
WELL WE WANT TO WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
MINISTRATION LEGISLATURE.
AND STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
CALIFORNIA GET WHAT THEY NEED
AND GET WHAT THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SO RICK
ROLLINS REPRESENTED ARKANSAS
SHIZHEN REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES
SO I WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES SO MANY OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
AND THOSE EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION -- FOR A STEP
FORWARD AND FUNDING AND REFORMS
TO OUR SYSTEM THAT ARE MUCH
NEEDED -- WE HAVE CHAMPIONS OF
IN ALL OF YOU IN BOTH PARTIES WE
HAD PERSON LIKE TO POINT OUT.
MY PERSONAL APPRECIATION IT HAS
THE OF TO THOSE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
BEEN HERE THROUGH THE BAD TIMES
AND NOW -- HOPEFULLY MOVING INTO
THE GOOD TIMES -- CENTER
MITCHELL CENTER BELL
PARTICULARLY WHO HAVE FOUGHT FOR
MANY YEARS SO -- FOR OUR FOR OUR
SERVICES SUCH AS A PARENT.
WHOSE SON'S BEEN SEARCHED -- FOR
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS NOW IN THE
SYSTEM AND SOMEONE WHO WORKED IN
THIS BUILDING FOR MANY YEARS
PRIOR TO BECOME INTO A LOBBYIST
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS BILL
THESE COMMUNITY.
IT GIVES ME GREAT HOPE THAT --
WE HAVE HOPE FOR THE FUTURE AND
THAT -- THIS IS A GOOD
INVESTMENT MOVING FORWARD IS NOT
PERFECT BUT I DO ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE SENATE.
IF ALL OF YOU WHO SUPPORTED THE
SENATE BUDGET VERSION -- WAS
WELL ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT MANY
OF US EXPECTED TO SEE OUT OF THE
PROCESS THIS YEAR AND IF WE ONLY
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN THE SENATE
VERSION OF THE BUDGET.
THROUGH THIS PROCESS I THINK ALL
OF US IN THE IN THE COMMITTEE
WOULD BE VERY VERY GRATEFUL WE
ALSO ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE.
OF THE ADMINISTRATION STEPPING
FORWARD AND LOOK FORWARD TO A A
GOOD -- ROBUSTA CONTINUATION OF
THAT -- RELATIONSHIP MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU THANK
MYSTERONS NEXT WITNESS.
I'M TERM MEMBERS TREAT THE
ANDERSON WITH THE ARE CAN YOU
SEE P. CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION --
WE WANTED KNOWLEDGE THE THE
ENORMOUS UNDERTAKING -- BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION IN
DELIBERATING THE FUTURE OF A
SYSTEM THAT SUPPORTS THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THE SENATE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
DISCUSSED AT THE PRELIMINARY
RESULTS OF THE DVS RATE STUDY IN
HEARD PUBLIC COMMENT THAT LENGTH
REGARDING THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY.
AND COMP COMPREHENSIVE RATE%
REFORM.
ALSO -- CENTER STERN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU CARRIED THE
PROPOSAL FOR A PERCENT INCREASE.
AND THE DOWN PAYMENT ON
STABILIZING THE FUTURE AND AS I
LOOK AT THE DIETS AS WELL.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU WHO
REALLY MADE SO MANY COMMENTS ON
BEHALF OF OUR COMMUNITY WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
WE MET WITH ALL OF YOU --
APPRECIATE SO MUCH OF THE EFFORT
AND ENERGY THAT YOU PUT INTO OUR
COMMUNITY -- WE REALLY WOULD
LIKE TO TO LET YOU KNOW THAT --
WE APPRECIATE EVERYTHING IN
TERMS OF HOW YOU'RE REALLY
WORKING TURN SIR ACCESS TO
QUALITY SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
THE RESULTS -- FROM FROM THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THE ARE THE
INVESTMENT SOME POLICY CHANGES
THAT WILL PROVIDE CRITICALLY
NEEDED TEMPORARY RELIEF TO SOME
OF THE SERVICES IN CRISIS AND
THAT'S SOME AND WE REALLY NEED.
TO STAY FOCUSED ON THE FACT THAT --
THAT MEANS THE ONLY BE A FIRST
STEP THAT THE PROMISE.
IS WE STILL NEED TO FULFILL THE
PROMISE.
THAT HAS BEEN MADE TO
CALIFORNIANS WITH IT THE WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE BILL
INCLUDES MANDATES FOR
STAKEHOLDERS -- AND THE
DISCUSSION AROUND COMPREHENSIVE
RIGHT REFORM BEGINNING THIS
SUMMER.
AT THE SAME TIME -- IT'S ACTIONS.
THAT'S REALLY GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE NOT DISCUSS AND THAT
WILL ULTIMATELY BENEFIT THE
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
BOTH THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
PASSED REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO TAKE ACTION TOWARDS
RATE REFORM IN NEXT BUDGET YEAR.
AND ALTHOUGH -- NON THIS BILL WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND ARE LEGISLATIVE
CHAMPION FILLING US INTO THEM
THAT REALIZATION NEXT YEAR.
COUPLE SPECIFICS ON ABOUT THE
TRAILER BILL FIRST WE THINK THE
COMMITTEE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE FOR WORK FOR THEIR WORK
ON SUSPENDING THE FOURTEEN DAY
UNIFORM HOLIDAY -- SCHEDULE
THAT'S BEEN SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT -- AT LENGTH FOR
YEARS A WE'D REALLY LIKE TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS ON THE
HALF THE BILLING AND SOCIAL WORK
IN CAMP EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
SECOND THE BILL CODIFIES WHO
GETS RATE INCREASES AND WHO
DOESN'T BASED ON THE DRAFT RATE
STUDIES IN PORT TO REMEMBER THAT
THE DRAFT.
THEREFORE AS THE RATE MODELS A
REVISED AND FINALIZED IN OCTOBER
THE RATE INCREASES MUST BE
REVISITED IN JANUARY OR THE
JANUARY BUDGET OR EARLIER ONE
THING I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD
IN ADDITION IS THAT -- I ECHO
THE COMMENTS AROUND EARLY START
IS -- THIS CRITICAL THAT WE WE
FIND EARLY STARS FONG THE OTHER
SERVICES THAT DID NOT GET
FUNDING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEE NONE -- WE HAVE A MOTION.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB AT ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN WELL WELL
I'D ARE ALSO.
HER DAUGHTER FOR TOTAL AYE JONES
JONES I LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE MONEY MORE
LOCK MORE LIKE I AM MORRELL
MORRELL I PAN ROTH SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
STONE STONE I AMBER.
LIGHT KASKI.
BUT BECAUSE HE AYE.
WELL HOW ABOUT THAT.
ELEVEN ZERO HOLD THAT I ITEM
OPEN TO LOOK FORWARD TO THE
FLOOR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
MOVING ON TO ITEM.
SIX PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
AB.
NINETY PLEASE COME IN.
IS IT A COMEBACK TO SKIP IT.
HOLD ON FOR A MOMENT -- TO CHECK
IN WITH -- FINANCE
COLLEAGUES
ITEM SIX AB NINETY PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON UPLAND SEUSS A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- SO THIS
IS REALLY ARE AB NINETY IS
REALLY ARE PENSION OMNIBUS BILL
AND I'M GONNA GO OVER IT VERY
HIGH LEVEL.
THE AT TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET PACKAGE PROVIDES FOR
ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS TO BOTH CAL
PERSON CAL STIRS TO PAY DOWN
RETIREMENT LIABILITIES.
AND ALSO PROVIDE GREAT RELIEF
FOR SCHOOL PENSION COSTS AT THE
SECRETARY CHANGES IN THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW THE STATE TO
IMPLEMENT THESE PAYMENTS.
AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
AT THIS POINT THANK YOU
QUESTIONS MEMBERS. THREE MORE
LAW.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THIS IS WHAT
YOU DO WITH THE BUDGET SURPLUS
YOU START PAYING DOWN.
YOUR DEBTS AND THE FACT THAT
WE'RE PUTTING.
MONEY INTO THE PERSIAN AND EVEN
FOR FOR CAL STARS WERE HELPING
OUT THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- IT'S
CERTAINLY A NICE GESTURE AS HIS
WERE LOOKING AT THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORTS IN THEIR EMERGING MANY
ACTUALLY -- BUT WE SHOULD BE
MAYBE EVEN THINK ABOUT DOING
SOMETHING SIMILAR FOR SCHOOLS
AND SCHOOLS OUR SCHOOLS RIVER
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE ALSO.
NINE DURING THE REVENUE --
COMPONENTS THAT WERE ENJOYING
RIGHT NOW WE PROBABLY COULD PUT
MORE INTO CALPERS AS WELL
[inaudible]
WE'RE SEEING [inaudible]
BETTER UP.
COMPENSATION TOTAL COMPENSATION
IS SALARIES BENEFITS DEFINED
BENEFIT PENSION PLAN RETIREE
MEDICAL.
AND YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE ALL.
INTERESTING COMPONENTS BUT IT'S
HARD. TO MOVE UP.
YOUR SALARIES WHEN YOU HAVE THE
OTHER -- THREE SO IF WE CAN
REDUCE THE UNFUNDED LIABILITIES
OLD THAT THERE MIGHT BE SOME
ROOM TO HELP SOME OF THESE
TEACHERS.
THAT ARE -- ON STRIKE BUT WE'VE
GOT TO THINK ABOUT MAYBE PUTTING
EVEN MORE SIDE MANAGER SO I'LL
I'LL SUPPORT THIS -- AND AND
GIVE AN ATTA BOY TO THE
GOVERNOR'S TEAM -- BUT WOULD
LOVE TO SEE A LITTLE MORE THANK
YOU.
QUESTION FOR MEMBERS.
WELL INDEED IN THE PREVIOUS
GOVERNMENT.
DESERVES SOME THANKS TO THE
GOVERNOR BROWN MADE ATTENTION
GIVEN TO THESE UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES AND TOWARDS GOVERNOR
NEWSOME.
AND INDEED WHATEVER WE DO HAVE
RESOURCES WE NEED TO DO WHATEVER
WE CAN AND HELPING LOCAL.
JURISDICTIONS ALSO.
IS IMPORTANT.
AND THAT'S WHY THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS MADE IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS WE STILL HAVE A
VERY LONG WAY TO GO.
AND WE HAVE TO BE AWARE OF
ACCRUING ADDITIONAL LONG TERM
OBLIGATIONS.
BUT THIS IS A GOOD START OR
CONTINUING ON THAT PATH THAT WE
STARTED A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY OTHER
COMMENTS SEE NONE PUBLIC COMMENT.
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN AND MEMBERS GI
SURPRISE SAID WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION.
WHAT IS SB AIR IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING THE WORK OF
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES?
AND FOR PROVIDING DE
PROPORTIONATE SHARE OF COURSE
OUT FOLKS TO WORK IN THE SCHOOLS
BUT THEY'RE NOT UNDERSTOOD IS
THERE AND OPPOSE INSTEAD SO
THANK YOU FOR THE FUNDING.
THANK YOU WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AB NINETY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS MITCHELL HI ANGEL I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN ONLINE BILL BILL I'D ARE
ALSO.
HER DAUGHTER FOR TOTAL AYE JONES.
JONES I'D LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
MONEY.
MORE LOOK MORE LIKE ON A MORAL.
I PAN.
ROTH.
INNER SKINNER ONLINE STERN.
STONE.
STONE AYE NUMBER BY KASKI
BECAUSE THE AYE.
THE VOTE OF TWELVE TO ZERO WILL
HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB.
ONE TWO STATE EMPLOYEES MO YOU
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
AFTERNOON MERRY ALTERMAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AB ONE OH
TO RATIFY IS A ONE YEAR CONTRACT
BETWEEN ADMINISTRATION AND
BARGAINING UNIT SIX THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL DO
NOT TAKE THE AFFECTS AND LESS
FUNDS ARE SPECIFICALLY
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
THE COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED
CONTRACT WITH CCPOA RESULTS IN
BUDGET YOUR COSTS -- TOTALING
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE POINT TWO
MILLION.
TIME INCLUDING BOTH THE CPO
MEMBERS AND RELATED EXCLUDE
EMPLOYEES.
WHEN INCLUDING THE JULY FIRST
2023% GENERAL SALARY INCREASE
TOTAL BUDGETARY COSTS?
ARE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION OVER THE ONE
YEAR CONTRACTS.
QUESTIONS THAT ARE MORE LOCK.
MADAM CHAIR OF MAY I ASK FOR THE
LA -- TO SPEAK TO THIS ITEM
CERTAINLY.
AND JUST TO CLARIFY THEIR THERE
IN THE ROOM AND ALWAYS AVAILABLE
THEY AREN'T AT THE DAIS --
BECAUSE AS THE PREVIOUS DELEO
KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY HAVE NOT
ALWAYS BEEN PRETTY TODAY'S FINAL
NEGOTIATIONS SO -- ON THIS ONE I
DO BELIEVE THEY HAVE A WHITE
PAPER SO IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
ALEJO I DON'T HAVE IT IN MY
MATERIAL CYCLE.
THAT'S AWFUL.
YOU KNOW THANKS FOR COMING
THANKS FOR IT IS ALSO AVAILABLE
ONLINE SEE.
IT'S AVAILABLE ONLINE ALSO.
BANKS ARE DESIGNED A BUSY DAY I
UNDERSTAND I READ IT THIS
WEEKEND.
HELLO NICK SCHROEDER WITH THE LA --
AS AS YOU INDICATED WE DID
RELEASE AN ANALYSIS OF MO YOU AS
IS REQUIRED BY LAW -- WE HAVE
TEN DAYS TO COMPLETE THE
ANALYSIS -- AND IN THAT ANALYSIS
WE FOUND THAT -- THE PAY
INCREASE IN PARTICULAR 3% PAY
INCREASE IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY IS NOT A JUSTIFIED FROM
AN ECONOMIC.
BASIS MORE FROM RECRUITMENT NOR
RETENTION BASIS -- AND THAT'S
LARGELY BASED ON THE FACT THAT
THE LAST -- COMPENSATION STUDY
THE MINISTRATION PROVIDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE WAS DONE IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND AT THAT TIME
THE HOMES UNIT SIX WAS FOUND TO
BE 40%.
ABOVE MARKET ABOVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COUNTERPARTS -- AND
SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN UNITS SIX
SALARIES HAVE KEPT PACE OR
EXCEEDED INFLATION -- AND JULY
FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN WILL
RECEIVE A 5%.
GENERAL SALARY INCREASE IN THE
3% GENERAL SALARY INCREASE
PROVIDED IN THE PROPOSEDAGREEMENT.
AND SO CONSIDERING THAT WE THINK
ALTHOUGH WE DO NOT HAVE A
COMPENSATION STUDY SUBMITTED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION.
WE THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO
ASSUME THAT THEY ARE STILL
COMPENSATED ABOVE MARKET.
AND WE DON'T THINK IT'S
JUSTIFIED.
THANK YOU ON AND ARE YOU STILL
EXPECTING THE COMPENSATION STUDY
[inaudible]
THAT.
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
ALTHOUGH THE STATE LAW REQUIRES
THE MINISTRATION TO SUBMIT A
COMPENSATION STUDY SIX MONTHS
BEFORE THE EXPIRATION OF ANIMAL
YOU THAT THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
NOT BE SUBMITTING A COMPENSATION
STUDY -- THIS YEAR.
SO THEN WHAT'S OF WHAT'S THE
PENALTY FOR NOT [inaudible]
PROVIDING IT.
IF IT'S DAYLIGHT.
THERE'S NO EXPRESSED PENALTY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM YOU'RE WELCOME
HERE THANK YOU LA YOU.
SENATOR BAIL OF WHEN YOU DO A
COMPENSATION SO YOU COMPARE.
THE SARS FOR KIND OF THE SAME.
AND WHAT.
CAN YOU GIVE AN EXAMPLE WHAT
KIND OF COMPARISON IS THERE.
OKAY WHAT WOULD YOU COMPARE.
TO A LOT MORE EACH COUNTY HAS
JAILS OR DETENTION CENTERS WITH
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE DEPUTY
SHERIFFS.
WHO SUPERVISE THE INMATES AND SO
THOSE WOULD BE THE MOST LIKELY --
COMPARATORS BUT YOU CAN ALSO
LOOK TO CORRECTIONAL OFFICER
CLASSIFICATIONS IN OTHER STATES --
WHICH WE DID DO IN -- USING BLS
DATA BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS
DATA -- AND BASED ON THE
NATIONAL COMPENSATION LEVELS WE
APPEAR TO BE HI LEE COMPENSATING
OUR OUR CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
RELATED OTHER STABLES.
RIGHT IS IF YOU CONTROL FOR COST
OF LIVING WERE IN THE TOP TEN I
THINK WE WERE THE SIXTH --
HIGHEST COMPENSATED EDITORS OF
COMPARISON TO LIKE.
SO YOU TAKE THE BIG COUNTIES.
YEAH THAT WAS A BIG
ORGANIZATIONS EARLY WOULD YOU
COMPARE TO THOSE YEAH SO WHAT WE
I MEAN WE LIKE I SAID WE ONLY
HAVE TEN DAYS TO DO OUR ANALYSIS
SO WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO DO A
FULL COMPENSATION STUDY BUT WHAT
WE DID DO IS LOOK AT JUST.
SALARIES. FOR TWELVE OF THE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE AND THOSE
ARE THE COUNTIES THAT EMPLOYEE
MORE THAN A THOUSAND UNITS.
SIX PLEASE -- AND LOOKING AT
THAT THERE WERE THREE OF THE
TWELVE COUNTIES THAT HAD SALARY
RANGES WITH TOP STEPS ABOVE THE
UNIT SIX SALLY RANGES BUT OTHER
THAN THAT.
UNIT SIX ABOVE ALL OF THEM BY AT
LEAST 5% [inaudible]
RIGHT.
ABOUT BY ABOUT 5% AT LEAST 5%
YES -- THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE DO I HAVE A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL IF YOU WANTED TO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS MITCHELL HI MITCHELL
AYE NIELSEN.
WELL BILL I'D ARE ALSO.
HER DAUGHTER FOR TOTAL AYE JONES
JONES ONLINE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MONNING.
MORE LOCK MORE LUCK NO MORALE
MORRELL NO PAN ROTH SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STONE STONE I AMBER MY KASKI
ACOSTA.
THE VOTE OF EIGHT TO TO THAT
ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN MOVING ON
TO OUR LAST AGENDA ITEM TODAY
ITEM EIGHT AB ONE ALL.
FIVE BUDGET ACTIVE TWENTY
NINETEEN THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
BUILDING A HOUSE.
ON THURSDAY -- AND INCLUDES TWO
KEY ITEMS THE FIRST IS WITH
REGARD TO COVER CALIFORNIA AT
EIGHT AUTHORIZES AND PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ABOVE WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED IN
THE NAY REVISION.
AND THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
BRINGS THE TOTAL FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR TO AROUND FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS --
MAKES A PENALTY REVENUE AND THEN
AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND AND THIS ALSO REDUCES OUT
OF POCKET COSTS FOR PEOPLE UNDER
110038% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL.
AS WELL AS PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
SUBSIDIES FOR PEOPLE BETWEEN
4100% AND 6100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
IN ADDITION THIS BUDGET BILL
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL ON ON
FUNDING FOR UC AND CSU FOR
ENROLLMENT INCREASES OF NEARLY
FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS AT UC AND
TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS AT CSU.
REFERS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
WITH THE BILL.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS THERE WE HAVE
A MOTION LET'S OPEN UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
JUST WANNA THINK THE CHAIR OF
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE SPEAKER ON
THE PUT TENS AND ALL OF YOUR
STAFF -- YOU'VE BEEN GREAT AND
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT YOU
HEARD OUR CONCERN WITH REGARDS
TO ENROLLMENT THAT PREVIOUS --
BUDGET THAT ENROLLMENT MONEY IN
THE CSU WASN'T NECESSARILY SPENT
ON NEW STUDENTS -- HAVING A SEAT
AT THE CSU WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BUDGET THAT
SAYS THAT IT'S YOUR INTENT BUT
THIS EIGHTY FIVE MILLION IS --
FOR IF THE IF YOUR INTENT IS FOR
NEW STUDENTS AND THAT'S WHAT I
THINK WE ALL AGREE THAT MONEY
WAS FOR SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
ALL BE VERY PROUD OF PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
AB ONE OF FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS MITCHELL.
BY MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN WELL.
THE AUDITOR ALSO HER TOTAL FOR
TOTAL AYE JONES JONES NO LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE MONEY BARLACH.
LOOK I'D MORAL.
MORAL NO PAN.
ROTH SKINNER SKINNER ONLINE
STERN STONE.
STONE NO NUMBER BY KASKI HI MY
BECAUSE HE AYE. SEVEN THREE WILL
HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN HAVING
ARRIVED AT THE END OF OUR AGENDA.
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK UP TO THE
TOP OF MEMBERS WHO HAVE JOINED
THIS -- WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FOR ITEM ONE AB
SEVENTY FIVE AB SEVENTY FIVE
MCGUIRE.
PAN SKINNER.
SKINNER ONLINE STERN -- FINE
[inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible] ONE UP PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FOR ITEM
TO AB SEVENTY EIGHT HEALTH
COMMITTEE.
AB SEVENTY A HER DAUGHTER
[inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING.
ROTH.
STERN STONE STONE NO
[inaudible] EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
WILL KEEP THAT ITEM OPEN ITEM
THREE AB.
SEVENTY NINE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AB SEVENTY NINE HER TITLE.
HER TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MONNING.
PAN.
I ROTH.
STERN STONE STONE I NUMBER.
THIRTEEN ZERO SIR THE RESCUE
HELP WITH.
GETTING THE SLAYER NOW -- NO.
THAT'S RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU -- WITH A VOTE OF
THIRTEEN TWO ZERO AB
[inaudible]
SEVENTY NINE PASSES.
ITEM FOR A. B..
EIGHTY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AB AT A DRAW ALSO.
HER DAUGHTER.
HER TOTAL AYE MCGUIRE MINING.
TOWN.
I STERN.
NUMBER.
THE VOTE OF EIGHTY THREE THAT
ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN ITEM FIVE
A. B. EIGHTY ONE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
NIELSEN.
THEY'RE ALSO.
MCGUIRE MINING.
PAN PAN AYE ROTH NUMBER.
WITH A VOTE OF TWELVE TO ZERO
THAT MEASURE KERRY'S PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM
SIX A. B. NINETY CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE ALSO.
MONNING PAN PAN AYE ROTH STERN
AMBERG [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
FUNNY NEY [inaudible] FOURTEEN
ZERO THE VOTE OF FOURTEEN ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
OF FILE ITEM SEVEN A. B..
ONE OH TWO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN -- ALSO
MCGUIRE MONNING.
FUNDING I PAN PAN AYE ROTH STERN
NUMBER.
VOTER TENDED TO ALL HOLD THAT
ITEM OPEN.
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB ONE OH FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
NIELSEN.
THEY'RE ALSO MCGUIRE MINING
MONEY I PAN PAN AYE ROTH STERN.
NUMBER.
THE VOTE OF NINE TO THREE WILL
HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN
.
ALL RIGHT OUR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL IN ITEM ONE A. B. SEVENTY
FIVE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MCGUIRE.
PAN AND I STERN.
IT WILL DELIVER FOOD YEAH YOU
WERE HERE WHEN WE FIRST GOT
STARTED.
ITEM TWO A. B. I'LL HOLD THAT
ITEM OPEN ITEM TO AB SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ARE TADO MCGUIRE MONEY.
MONEY I ROTH.
ROTH AYE STERN.
IN A FULL ANWER.
THE VOTE OF TEN FIVE A HOLE THAT
ITEM OPEN GONNA JUMP DOWN TO
FILE ITEM.
FOR AB AT.
VOTERS EIGHT TO THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
YOU'RE AWESOME.
MCGUIRE MONEY MONEY I STERN
NUMBER [inaudible]
NUMBER GUY. TEN THIRTY TEN TO
THREE WILL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN --
GONNA JUMP DOWN ONCE AGAIN TO
FILE ITEM.
EIGHT AB ONE OH FIVE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
NIELSEN THEY'RE ALSO MCGUIRE
ROTH.
ROTH AYE STERN.
NUMBER NUMBER I 11-3.
VOTE OF 11-3.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
OF MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM I
THINK I DIFFICULT ALPHA.
I CLOSED OUT SEVERAL CITY NUMBER
EXCEPT WAY.
IF THE CLOTHES ARE CLOSED WOULD
YOU CAN VOTE ON THE FLOOR SIR.
FILE ITEM FIVE DID I CLOSE OUT
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
YES AB AT [inaudible]
ONE IT'S CLOSED.
CAN YOU TELL US THE REMAINING
ITEMS THAT ARE OPEN.
AB ONE THAT WOULD [inaudible]
OKAY.
I CLOSER REMINDING THIS IS THE
BOTTOM ON THE FLOOR.
SOUNDS GOOD TO ME ALL OF YOUR
CLOTHES.
NO SEVENTY SAYS OPEN
[inaudible] SIX OKAY. FOR THE
FILE ITEMS THAT REMAIN OPEN FOR
VOTER FILE ITEMS ONE TWO FOUR
AND SEVEN OKAY.
CAESAR NIELSEN IS HEREBY ADDED
ANYBODY ELSE SENATOR ROTH OF THE
VOTE AND ALL THOSE.
LET'S OPEN THE ROLE ON FILE ITEM.
SEVEN IF YOU WANTED TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I ALSO.
MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE.
AB STERN I'M SORRY ROTH.
ROTH AYE STERN THE NUMBERS.
IF YOU GO TO SELL YEAH.
THE VOTER THIRTEEN TO TO THAT
[inaudible]
MEASURE KERRY'S.
LET'S OPEN THE ROLE ON FILE ITEM
ONE A. B. SEVENTY FIVE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE ONLINE STERN.
THE VOTE OF TWELVE TO FOR THAT
MEASURE KERRY'S.
UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM TO WRITE AB SEVENTY EIGHT
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FURTADO.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE I STERN.
VOTED ELEVEN FIVE THAT MEASURE
KERRY'S.
FILE ITEM FOR A. B..
EIGHTY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE ALSO MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE [inaudible]
STERN.
11-3 THAT MEASURE KERRY'S AND WE
JUST DID SEVEN RIGHT.
EVERYTHING ELSE I CLOSE OUT SIR
[inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH WE GOT IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COMMITTEE STANDS ADJOURNED